[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau numéro
deux va y paix avec mon invité nikita
kristi lynn on va essayer de comprendre
qui se joue actuellement en russie
bonjour bonjour patrice person
confrontation mais elle fait rêver dans
de nous rencontrer et de vous
interviewez alors on va parler de tout
petit peu de vous d'abord vous appelez
de nikita christine in alors ça va donc
tout le monde doit vous être plus vous
êtes n'y aurait rien je suis une heure
aussi exactement dans une vie qui
s'appelle krasnoïarsk c'est en sibérie
aussi c'est à cette heure de vol
d'oiseau de paris donc c'est assez loin
il est assez méconnue et j'y suis venu
en france à l'âge de trois ans c'est une
ville exactement soit un peu moins d'un
million d'habitants mais ça se développe
assez rapidement d'accord et vous êtes
venu en france à l'âge de trois ans et
vous avez vécu à montigny le bretonneux
exactement exactement j'ai vécu
rocard sédation de riz durant une
quinzaine d'années attendu en enfance et
mon adolescence
après alors vous avez fait des études
est diplômé de sciences po
l'examen est actuellement recherché ce
qu'on appelle un véhicule c'est ça c'est
ça votre accent international en
entreprise dans un pays anglo saxon en
arkansas passé alors évidemment ainsi
peser tant né en russie vous intéressé
de très près ce qui se passe en russie à
la politique russe depuis toujours
ça commençait vraiment en 2017
alors pourquoi en 2017 parce que alexeï
navalni cette année-là a publié un film
révélation révélations sur tous les
biens que possède à l'époque le premier
ministre dimitri medvedev
un film qui dure 45 minutes qui a fait
38 millions de vues sur youtube en
quelques mois ça a été un véritable
départ pour moi dans mon intérêt pour la
politique est vraiment comprendre ce qui
se passe donc dans mon pays de naissance
alors vous êtes un soutien d'alexei
navalni exhale excellent navalni c'est
le principal
opposant à vladimir poutine qui s'énerve
ennemis alors on a en temps on a
commencé à entendre parler d' alexeï
navalni en 2011 donc lors des élections
législatives en russie cette année là il
y a eu des fraudes en masse c'est à dire
que les observateurs des élections se
faisait systématiquement expulsés des
bureaux de vote il n'y a avait pas
encore cette époque-là de caméras nokia
eu des très gros soupçon de fraude de la
part du parti de vladimir poutine qui
est russie unie donc aux majorités ans
au parlement russe depuis 2002 d'accord
et cette année là donc à l'excès nava
nuit lui a pris la tête de l'opposition
donc la tête de ce mouvement fait qu'ils
dénoncent les fraudes massives et ce
mouvement a commencé à rassembler de
plus en plus de personnes qui me
soutiennent pas forcément alexeï navalni
mais qui dénonce les fraudes
systématiques du système électoral de
poutine et c'est à partir de cette année
là qui la conservent un nom partout tant
ici parce que c'est un régime qui est il
ya de la corruption il ya des
probablement des fraudes dans les votes
qu'est qu'il est là la tendance ici vous
devez par exemple par rapport à la
politique française
si on devait dire quelle est la tendance
du parti politique de napanee c'est quoi
alors il faut savoir que nous valons n'a
pas vraiment de partis politiques il ya
deux raisons la première raison c'est
parce que tout simplement on ne laisse
pas son parti politique sont régis
enregistrés auprès du ministère de la
justice justice russe
navalni a essayé plusieurs fois de la
famille à partir de 2002 puis 2012 il a
essayé plusieurs noms il a rassemblé
donc plusieurs congrès en but
dans le but de danseurs enregistré son
parti puis de le présenter dans les
différentes sélections mais à chaque
fois la demande a été refusée pour des
prétextes souvent assez assez
fantastique
donc voilà administrative à la tribune
pratique mais évidemment pièce
le bal avant d autres comme ça voilà et
dans un deuxième temps
navalni n'a pas de parti politique parce
qu'il rassemble vraiment des personnes
de tous les horizons mais il ressemble
au fond de l'opposition voilà c'est ça à
poutine en boxer ça donc ça serait ça va
les gars est l'ennemi russe
en fait il est identique à alex et d'un
ami qu'il soit de gauche qu'ils soient
de droite
généralement il n'y a pas vraiment de
couleurs il n'y a pas vraiment il n'ya
pas vraiment cette attribution la
retraite dans les sections du festival
et on peut retrouver vraiment à large
spectre de citoyen russe et pourquoi
alors on va rentrer un peu dans les
détails de ce qui s'est passé dans les
dernières semaines mais pourquoi poutine
a l'air de craindre tellement alexeï
navalni alors il ya plusieurs raisons à
cela
dans un premier temps lesquels elle
aussi principal d'avec saint-vallier
c'est évidemment internet puisqu'il n'a
pas de facto d'accès aux chaînes
télévisées russes ils voient la vérité
on ne voit jamais on n'a même pas le
droit de prononcer son pour aller plus
loin il ne prononce jamais le nom de la
vallée pour éviter de lui donner de la
visibilité et dans les journaux
télévisés russes
c'est toujours un verre c'est toujours
ce citoyen
ce malade dans le 15 mai en raison par
exemple c'est toujours en fait des déçus
au nom donc bien entendu tout en passant
de vanille mais le nom de shadow navalni
n'ai jamais prononcé par le président
c'est systématique
mega est lui même alors il vient d'où il
est la vallée s'étend aux sept ans
moskovitz et 1 minute donc qui a
commencé à faire de la politique à
partir d'un âge assez jeune à partir de
une trentaine d'années il était d'abord
avocat
et puis donc après tout cas voilà et
puis à partir des événements que donc
que je viens de mentionner en 2011 la
commencer à fonder donc un vrai
mouvement avec à large spectre de
partisans derrière lui qui se sont
joints à lui est ce que l or malgré des
difficultés administratives la
possibilité d'enregistrer un parti
est-ce qu'il a eu des élus alors c'est
justement un des grands enjeux
un des grands enjeux des des élections
en russie dont qu'elles soient
municipales ou qu'ils soient légiste
ifs en fait nani a lancé ce qu'on
appelle un vote intelligent c'est à dire
nous nous donc on sait très bien que les
candidats de l'opposition ne sont
systématiquement pas abus aux élections
cependant il ya des exceptions notamment
dans les régions de moscou où vraiment
le pouvoir est plus confiant très
localement ou donc il ya moins ce
système de fraude massive d'un système
de corruption qui s'annonce ce qui est
un peu moins d'argent
donc il a lancé ce système de vote
intelligent si bien entendu c'est
terrible je vais expliquer tout ça si
doc ses partisans sont admis aux
élections il n'y a pas de souci donc on
veut napalm il appelle à voter pour ses
partisans
mais dans la majorité des cas de ses
partisans seront jamais adieu élections
c'est là qu'intervient de votre
intelligent tout simplement on va voir
dans la cire contre la circonscription
électorale nous qui est le candidat qui
a le plus de chances de remporter
l'élection
face aux représentants du parti russie
unie qui bien entendu est un partisan de
poutine donc on va donc on va il ya un
travail d' analyse un travail de sondage
un travail sociologique qui est fait et
alexina vanille à appelle à voter pour
le candidat qui a le plus de chances de
remporter le dans la construction a
unique objectif pour que le président
pour que le candidat de russie unie ne
gagne pas donc là on va un peu au-delà
de la couleur politique sait vraiment
tout faire pour que les touristes
chinois là pour que quel que soit quel
que soit le regard de l'opposant tout
faire pour que le parti de poutine sur
le mans possible représenté dans les
instances du pays
et ça marche ils allaient au parlement
actuellement c'est quoi là là là
évidemment le parti de poutine et est
largement majoritaire mais deux c'est
pratiquement que des députés pro poutine
où il ya des quelques opposants alors il
faut savoir que en russie les dernières
élections législatives en 2016 donc leur
vague où poutine
ça fait vraiment sur une très grande
popularité donc notamment après les
événements
de crimée et notamment après après ce
patriotisme qui est monté je suis va
planter voilà donc vivre patrie
exactement encore 2016 ya eu des
élections législatives à une très grande
majorité le la russe de russie unie donc
le parti de vladimir poutine a remporté
quasiment les trois quarts du ciel
généralement et il faut savoir que si
l'opposition donc l'opposition du
système parce que la vanille en fait
c'est une position hors système
puisqu'il ne peut pas de facteur je vais
avoir un parti politique est une
question du système fait ce sont donc en
partie le communiste en partie un parti
d'extrême droite aussi qui a assez peu
de partisans mais qui a quand même
présent parlement et le parti voilà un
peu un peu un peu du centre mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est vraiment des
partis depuis son du système
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont toujours fait
aller dans le sens de vladimir poutine
malgré qui joue l'image d'une salle
d'eau et il ya des élections
législatives à venir en fait au mois de
septembre 2021 et c'est là que le vote
intelligent risque de changer la donne
et que poutine avec ces décisions très
impopulaire notamment de l'âge de la
retraite notamment avec l'empoisonnement
d'alex et ma famille avec une économie
en chute
oui llc et dme mars très mal à ces
services et le retour de la pauvreté il
ya beaucoup de facteurs qui sont pas
très favorables au gouvernement poutine
alors revenons à cet empoisonnement
parce que c'est la preuve que poutine
craint navalni donc alors sais pas si on
peut dire il l'a fait au président tout
cas il était empoisonnée par les
services russes ça fait pas de doute
pour se soigner il est allé soigner en
allemagne
exactement à la clinique charité à
berlin et il revient en russie alors là
il ya quand même quelque chose d'assez
sidérant c'est le courage de ce type
quoi c'est le courage d'avec son avenir
et ceux ci un geste fort que malgré le
fait que les services secrets bien
entendu sous un contrôle de la dioxine
qui lui même était à la tête des
services secrets
jusqu'à 80 98 le fsb désormais cti
montrent que malgré l'environnement
malgré que en russie ma famille mes amis
mes partisans ont fait on consulte des
répressions tous les jours donc ça va ça
va pas une simple agression de vue à
l'interdiction de se présenter à la
famille d'alexandre à lille rennes et
ses partisans et ses soucis on va dire
les plus médiatisés médiatisé
malgré cela malgré malgré le fait même
que avant le retour d'alex et navalni en
russie on lui a annoncé que si alex et
si vous revenez contre vous on a déjà
annoncé une procédure une procédure
pénale dans le but de revoir un jugement
qui date de 2014 en fait tout simplement
pour faire court pour vous confirmer en
prison les semaines à venir il est malin
du système n'ayez pas peur du n'ai pas
peur du système si la vérité est de
votre côté n'ai pas peur de le faire
savoir
il a appelé tous ses soutiens à se
mobiliser et en fait c'est là où il a
été plus intelligent cela ou la grille
parce qu'il n'a pas cédé à la peur que
vladimir poutine
et c'est en train d'installer depuis 20
ans dans la tête des russes parce que
pour lui moi la société politisés mais
c'est pauline c'est pour pour contrôler
en fait livré les différents les
différents pôles pôle important de la
russie alexeï navalni revenus ça a été
la terre la plus médiatisée
très clairement dans le monde en cette
fin de mois c'est un coup c'est un coût
qui était gagné par la vanille même si
bien évidemment il a permise était
extrêmement populaire auprès des russes
d'ailleurs de se montrer aussi
courageuse dirait il a été empoisonné il
revient alors il ya là il ya une
procédure us qui s'était dire qu'il
était condamné à trois ans et demi de
prison pour ne pas s'être présenté au
contrôle judiciaire et pour cause ils
avaient été empoisonnés ils étaient en
train d'être soignés en france en
allemagne pour ça qu'il a été couronné
de succès c est absolument ubuesque donc
il ya ce on a l'impression que
le courage c'est du côté de laval ni la
peur du côté de poutine en un mot pour
conclure c'est ça exactement en fait
c'est tendance qui s'inverse de papeete
depuis de nombreuses années en fait
blasio poutine fait tout pour que la
société russe sur le léman politisé
pose-t-il loquace intéresse le moins
possible à ce qui se passe pour
continuer à partager les ressources
principales de la russie a avancé que
l'assistant pis les plus des blés plus
riches du monde
nous avons des ressources nationales
bout du banc nous avons toutes ces
richesses là tout est fait pour se
partager les richesses entre poutine et
ses amis et poutine a très peur de ce
réveil citoyen russe et c'est pour ça
que nous on assiste que je vous ai à des
actions très a su très absurde comme ce
qui va se passer avec alexeï navalni et
la leyre la russie entre ans s'est
réveillé sur ce sujet eh bien merci
merci infiniment nikita et christine on
aura l'occasion de reparler parce que
les videmment l'année de la situation
évolue il va y avoir ces élections on va
voir aussi quel va être le sort d'alexei
navalni dans les prochaines semaines
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup patrice
merci
[Musique]